maman c'est quoi ça il nous faut
d'autres et ça
ça nous fera du boulot en plus et nous
on ne sait pas gérer la vente en ligne
tu es vraiment vintage tard téléphone
non comment tu fais pour parler à tes
amis
mon ami c'est ma mère
avec des moustaches
qui êtes vous
néanmoins pour le gazole il travaille
zoguehi ne drague au moins un autre côté
le coma non sortez de chez moi que tu te
mettes alignant mayotte producteurs y à
quoi dans la valise
qu'est ce qui a je vais bien je te jure
ça m'inquiète dit que j'allais bien
c'est qui cette femme on s'est battu on
ne lui restait plus que
je me souviens je les entend des cris et
tout le temps je n'avais pas envie que
tu la connaissent
et bien certains coréens pensent que les
difficultés de la vie sont causés par
les esprits tourmentés de leur sens être
quelque chose de femmes
c'est ça que tu veux tu peux même
endroit où reposer en paix
j'arrive un peu
savoir sur quoi d'autre tu m'as menti
ce
que j'ai fait je lui ai fait pour toi ça
suffise mon fait
tu vas les 1000 par
il est issu